I've been home alone all day hey
everyone its Hali so I got two requests
to do the brick mansion trailer with
Paul Walker which is super sad because
the last movie he did before he died
thank you Diablo xxx mm for suggesting
that and Sergio Cervantes I think that's
how you say your name thank you guys
because that really means a lot that you
want me to do this so I'm gonna do it
yes I see that if you're a gangster you
don't clap you're a gangster
you're shooting about shot at a joke to
make fun of your movie okay let me just
tell you a little something about my
taste in movies
I cannot stand action movies that have
to do with just drugs and jumping off of
things and explosions and not like an
actual real plot I'm pretty sure Ryan
thought this trailer looked amazing cuz
he's a guy and guys love explosions and
useless action it seems like one of
those movies that belongs on Netflix
which I feel really bad because Paul
Walker is so good-looking and amazing he
should have gone out like a bang the way
Heath Ledger did with Dark Knight this
is no Joker is there the joke I'm not
gonna watch it but all you guys out
there feel free feel free to fangirl
over it I'm just not one of those girls
I hope you liked it subscribe to the
real rejects cuz Brian does like this
trailer subscribe to him actually just
did a really funny short film with Ryan
on my channel I wrote it he improved a
bit it turned out hilarious so check
that out on my channel and if you like
it you can subscribe if not watch this
trailer but thanks I'll see you guys
soon peace out